Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg New Year's
resolution is to fix Facebook he writes
in a post we currently make too many
errors enforcing our policies and
preventing misuse of our tools vladimir
duthiers of our streaming network cbsn
shows us why changing facebook is a
complicated flat good morning good
morning complicated indeed Mark
Zuckerberg has been setting yearly
personal challenges since 2009 he
previously ran 365 miles traveled across
the country and learned Mandarin this
year his goal is not about personal
growth but to do a better job running
his company Facebook has the power to
connect people around the world but in
his latest post founder Mark Zuckerberg
acknowledges his company has caused
divisions Facebook has a lot of work to
do he wrote whether it's protecting our
community from abuse and hate defending
against interference by nation-states or
making sure that time spent on Facebook
is time well spent
I don't want anyone to use our tools to
undermine democracy Zuckerberg spent
much of 2017 on the defensive he
initially dismissed the idea fake news
on Facebook helped elect President Trump
as quote crazy but then was forced to
backtrack our teams have found and shut
down thousands of fake accounts that
could be attempting to influence
elections in many other countries New
York Times technology columnist Farhad
Manjoo I think he has come to notice the
ways that you know his technology is
changing the world in in kind of huge
shattering ways he's committing himself
in a very personal way and suggesting
he's personally responsible on Thursday
Zuckerberg Post also acknowledged the
perception Facebook may now be too big
and too powerful members of Congress
agreed you've created these platforms
and now they are being misused and you
have to be the ones to do something
about it or we will I think this could
also be an effort to head that off to
try to say we're kind of policing
ourselves you can hold off on policing
us
Zuckerberg offered few specifics on how
he plans to accomplish his personal
challenge for 2018 one thing he said he
would do was convene groups of experts
to help him work through the issues he
will also look at how encryption and
crypto currencies like Bitcoin might be
used to improve Facebook services and I
think he recognizes finally that this is
not just a place where we share vacation
photos and where we interact with our
parents but a main distributor of
information what a shocking concept
I mean seriously we talked about YouTube
yesterday it's a big deal these are big
big questions for the its before the
Senate investigations that's what he's
trying to get ahead of thank you